[Music]
[Music]
hey man there's old man ripoff man hey
man I'm se gonna say man I don't mean
man I'm a bachelor party man talk to
this man right here man yeah way to meet
it yeah yeah man the other hand man ah
tell me man no yeah man aliens man
[Music]
three
[Music]
to what
holy haberdashery holy ravioli holy
schizophrenia hooli : a donut holy
birthday cake
holy ricochet holy fruit salad holy
bouncing boiler plated holy
impregnability
I have a bad feeling about this I've got
a bad feeling about this
oh I have a bad feeling about this a bad
feeling about this
I'm a bad feeling about this
I got a bad feeling about this she's
about 6 feet past the three-point line
and she just does this I wasn't even
thinking get it in it was like a wild
thing yeah yeah yeah I dig your style
too man
yeah thanks ma'am yeah yeah thanks man
hey man take care of man gotta get back
to do the vines
go front oh me oh my
[Music]
get out of the way join
[Music]
I'd knocked it off if I was you
I am your father I am your father
I am your stoner Luke I am your father
yo soy tu papa
[Music]
[Music]
let's get out of here let's get out of
here just get out let's get out here
let's get out good eye let's get out of
here let's get out of here let's go
let's get out let's get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you really do justice
I'm a man of my word you're done harvest
of Domino's KFC and it always delicious
Taco Bell - big red or get out of my
face we should come back to this Apple
piece instead of this table and have a
family meal that's a great idea mom
[Applause]
[Music]
force be with you may the force be with
you and force be with you man Bitto
force be with us and may the force be
with you
hey - watch with insomnia nothing's real
everything's far away and flower blue
tie you want me to deprioritize but I
was a juicer
[Music]
only more bounty
[Music]
Thank You Steven Speilberg Steven the
great collaborator Thank You Steven
thank you the Academy I'm so grateful to
you saving a beloved skipper Steven
Spielberg I came back I have more
thinking of Steven to do thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw